I extremely awkward when I first ordered
one in America though did they know what
it was no I just yelled the words
in the bottom it was like it was like a
record I was like can I get a website
like the record scratch and the bar went
silent and I was like oh I guess that's
not a drink
I lad Bible I'm Margot Robbie and we are
going to play a game of do you even know
me animal time is I'm gonna be eating a
load of Australian and British snacks
and telling you which is the far
superior one which I'm pretty sure will
be the Australian ones but we could test
it out you should follow that Bible it's
really good by the way what do I keep
with me every night in bed a your
husband
a packet of biscuits in case I get
hungry
B air pods because my own snoring wakes
me up okay we'll see a stuffed toy
animal called bunny bunny
yeah
yeah when did you get bunny the day I
was born
it doesn't look anything like it doesn't
doesn't remotely resemble a bunny rabbit
anymore she's so well that
my koala as well oh you do oh good do
you sleep with it every night though
every night okay and my husband this
because he's like this is so weird that
we have to be in bed number he waits
until he thinks I'm asleep and then he
throws bunny out of it no yeah and I get
so mad I'm like take everybody out of
bed oh the things bunny has seen
his seats
Forex about his classic As It Gets in
Australia versus John Smith's I don't
know John Smith's Yorkshire smooth ale
um
again it just tastes like home to me and
I have so many great memories associated
with it
oh that's awful that is so bad is that
meant to be a good beer not to offend
anyone up north I love going out in
Manchester but just I just would highly
recommend to try Forex in future tequila
is the best shot to do on a night out
I had to hear the shots last night
and I am regretting it you don't
strongly disagree that tequila took the
best shots no but then what is the best
shot I'm partial to a Jager Bomb oh
really because you get you know you get
the kick of the Red Bull there yes but
the best shot is in Australia and excuse
my language it's called a wet shop okay
and it is the most delicious shot it
like it has no one's mad about having
it's mainly vodka and then topped up
with peach schnapps a bit of cranberry
juice and a squeeze of lime no it's
delicious it has like 10 of them the
word schnapps just brings up like oh
I've had about too many too many
memories those shots sounds amazing
they're so good snaps so much I was um
extremely awkward when I first ordered
one in America though did they know what
it was oh I just yelled the words
in the bottom I was like it was like a
record as well I was like can I get a
web like the record scratch and the bar
went silent and I was like oh I guess
that's not a drink here in the time it
takes this horse to escape name five
websites uh BuzzFeed blood Bible Google
Hot Sugar red juice
because she's kicking my ass can we
start this game over
the wears off I like I'm brain dead in
my opinion
what is the best prank I pulled as a
child a put a fart cushion under my
teacher's chair and was never found out
B put gravy in the shower head at home
so my brother had a nasty shower
C faked my own death for a babysitter
like you would have done all of these
things
it's gravy with your brother isn't it no
it's not I faked my own death did you
really I really didn't like the
babysitter no story of that it's a great
story I'll tell you after come on do you
want to hear it now do we have time
we're plenty of time well
our usual babysitter Talia who was like
a high school student and I adored her
so much uh my mom maybe she had exams or
something I'm not sure but my mom got
another babysitter in this old lady and
she was really grumpy and mean and I was
so stuffed that we didn't have Talia
anymore and um in in defiance I was just
not going to listen to anything this old
mean lady babysitter had to say she was
like go have your bath and I was like no
we're just like go take a bath
you are going to pay for this in my head
I said that and then I went and I took a
giant kitchen knife and ketchup and I
lay naked on the tiles outside the
bathroom covered myself and catch up and
put the knife next to me and I lay there
I like I committed I lay there for 40
minutes on these cold tiles and I
remember thinking like she has got to
come check on me soon it's very
irresponsible actually for her not to
come check soon but eventually she did
come and I almost gave her a heart
attack anyway she didn't come back she
didn't come back
I once woke up with the worst hangover
and I only had two Advil like it was my
only two Ibuprofen so they were like it
was like gold dust and I like
immediately went to take it grabbed the
glass to the bed it was straight vodka
and I was like I was shocked though I
was like what to do do I swallow the
Vodka because then I get the Advil or do
I screw it all out what did you do I
ended up drinking it because they just
canceled each other out nothing happened
The Hangover did not improve hair of the
dog does that work doesn't work on me do
you ever do that it doesn't work on me
yeah tim tams
this
penguins
tim tams
amazing so good now my husband thinks
that penguins are better because they
come with a joke why was The Penguin's
head so cold I don't know where did they
say the answer I'm probably just an
idiot and I'm missing it
doesn't even come close 10 times a far
superior for sure I prefer dressing down
to dressing up
dressing down I don't prefer it I'm not
going to strongly disagree with this
statement I just you know I feel like
there's a time and place for everything
yeah right yeah and like there's a time
and place for dressing down yeah I think
I'm I'm in dressing up mode right now we
are both we are so I'm on this side we
have tables on the Press on the Barbie
press tour I mean I'm a little bit
dressed down now as you can tell I
didn't try this is maybe the most
dressed down I've been in a month yeah
you were very subdue it's such a muted
pink it's more of a salmon today you're
like not trying Barbie yeah this is
low maintenance Barbie today with all my
Jewels why didn't I want to call them
shelves they're not cocktails and
tell me what a shell is I don't
know this is replicating out my beach my
beach um little outfit was this custom
yeah I love it what is my favorite book
series ever
a the Twilight Saga B 50 Shades C Harry
Potter it's Harry I know I was too easy
though too easy you knew it was going to
be too easy yeah what else are you in
do you know I did
it's a bit of a soft it's a bit of a raw
point for me but I did the test on the
Pottermore website which is the legit
one and I'm actually in Hufflepuff and I
was really upset about that to begin
with but then I read why and actually I
think yeah why why powerful Puffs are
actually very loyal friends and very
hard-working people that makes sense
thanks lad Bible thanks for having me
you shouldn't make an Instagram account
for your pet oh thank you disagree with
that I feel like that's the best usage
you've got a cute hat yeah I would love
to see your videos of a cute pet I think
animal videos and pictures are the best
and highest purpose of Instagram